as the titular character of the drama
series the good doctor Dr Sean Murphy
has faced great adversity and made great
triumphs these are the highest of the
highs and the lowest of the lows for
Sean and those closest to him more than
a year ahead of the covid-19 pandemic
the good doctor forced its doctors to
deal with a quick spreading pathogen in
the season 2 fall finale episode
quarantine the installment found Saint
bonaventure's ER on lockdown as a virus
laid Siege to the hospital the drama
takes place as things are already
ramping up amid holiday madness and the
pressure is already heightened for Sean
who finds the sensory assault of
Christmas lights and holiday chaos
chipping away at his composure to make
matters worse Hospital visitors begin
freaking out emergency surgeries are
needed Park's son has a severe asthma
attack and some of the doctors are among
those taking ill amid all of the
frenzies Sean begins to hyper focus on a
buzzing overhead light that continues to
break his concentration a sign that he
is beginning to experience sensory
overload the light is buzzing
I don't hear anything it's loud and very
distracting it needs to be fixed things
reach a fever pitch when limb collapses
while walking Morgan through surgery as
Park screams for someone to help his son
Sean finally hits his Breaking Point
covering his ears and curling up in a
fetal position right in the middle of
the emergency room walkway as alarmed
staff and patients look on although it's
a scary moment for Sean and the nursing
staff Morgan's quick thinking saves the
day when she realizes that getting him
to focus on the surgery is just the
thing to help him calm down
as a neurologically atypical individual
Sean sometimes struggles to communicate
information with the same ease as his
neurotypical colleagues that's all right
however because Sean's other workplace
gifts far exceeds the communication
challenges he encounters from time to
time when Dr Lim assigns Sean his first
surgery in first case second base Sean
feels confident even though his number
one detractor Dr Andrews has doubts
about whether Murphy is up to the
challenge although the surgery starts
auspiciously Sean suddenly walks out of
the operating room halfway through the
surgery can't can't do this what can you
do no don't no no no no no no
John then proceeds to Pace the hallway
while struggling to articulate what he's
thinking as a baffled Park Andrews and
Lim look on just as Andrews and Lim are
concluding Sean is suffering a meltdown
that demonstrates how unfit he is for
the job a light bulb goes off over
Park's head as he realizes Sean is
trying to tell them something after
calming down Sean explains that the
patient who would have been left with a
feeding tube as a result of the plan
surgery could receive a more advanced
operation but it would mean Sean has to
Forfeit his case the moment demonstrates
how capable Shawn is of synergy with his
colleagues his ability to overcome his
own challenges and his willingness to
put Patients First
from the moment Leah knocked on Sean's
apartment door it was clear they had
chemistry still the path to true love
isn't always easy and both Sean and Leah
had a lot of growing up to do before
they were ready to start a relationship
things between the pair get Rocky after
Carly breaks things off with Sean
encouraging him to tell Leah how he
feels about her in the season 3 episode
autopsy Sean follows Carly's advice and
confesses his feelings for Leah she is
quick to reciprocate them but tearfully
says they can't be together remaining
silent when he asks if it's because of
his autism Sean spends the next few
episodes in a dark hole and lashes out
at everyone around him in Anger
eventually he decides to vandalize
Leah's car in the hope that it will make
him feel better however he can't bring
himself to do it and instead delivers a
brutal takedown telling Leah she doesn't
respect him no one likes her and she
deserves to end up alone you acted like
you cared about me
but you don't even respect me the
interaction is distressing and cruel
even if Leah badly needs a wake-up call
to confront her ableism and selfishness
one of the things that made the early
difficulties between Sean and Leah so
painful is that Leah wasn't just
rejecting him outright she really does
love him but genuinely worries that a
relationship between two high
maintenance people would be far too
difficult however as she takes time to
think things over her feelings for Sean
only continue to grow and she is finally
forced to face them when she fears she
might lose him for good the Revelation
comes in season 3's penultimate episode
hurt which puts Sean on the rescue team
in the aftermath of an earthquake that
leaves some of Saint bonaventure's
people including Leah trapped in a
brewery Sean sets out to rescue her but
ends up helping a woman named Vera
instead while trapped in awaiting rescue
Sean pours his heart out to Vera without
realizing that Leah can hear him from a
walkie-talkie before he can bring her to
safety and Aftershock traps them both
flooding the sub-basement as a horrified
Leah listens in over the radio as Leah
fears for his safety Sean pours out his
heart to Vera here makes me
more after Sean's confession in
Aftershock then hits flooding the
basement and Sean and Vera are trapped
in with their lives at stake Vera
convinces Sean to move on from Leah if
they make it out alive when he finally
emerges from the building a waiting Leah
greets him with a kiss telling him that
he makes her feel the same way having
finally realized how much better their
lives are together
it's established early in the good
doctor that Sean's parents failed him
badly Sean's alcoholic father was
horribly abusive to Sean and his brother
Steve he berated Sean for his autism
eventually he drove Sean and his brother
Steve to run away from home which leads
to Steve's accidental death with such a
tragic backstory its Little Wonder Sean
is hesitant to go see his estranged
father when he learns he has a terminal
illness although his father Ethan Murphy
initially apologizes to Sean he does so
by playing the victim blaming his
actions on his inability to help his
autistic son in friends and family his
words are triggering causing Sean to
unleash his anger telling his father
he's a bad person you killed my rabbit
you killed my rabbit
and you killed my brother after sleeping
on his anger Sean returns to forgive his
father but Ethan responds with more
abuse telling Sean that he is weak and
it's his fault his brother died it's a
dark moment in Sean's life that reminds
Sean The Murphys were never his family
except by Blood
Sean first meets Dr Glassman after he
and Steve run away in search of a doctor
for Sean's rabbit while glass men can't
save their pet he gives them his phone
number in case they need anything which
leads to Sean to call him after Steve's
accident although Sean is eventually
placed in foster care he remains in
touch with classmen who serves as a
surrogate father and helps him get hired
at Saint Bonaventure after Medical
School through the ensuing years their
relationship faces various trials and
strains but they remain close despite
everything on Sean's wedding day
Glassman gives Sean two rings passed
down through his family that he had
intended to give to his late daughter as
Glassman attempts to tie Sean's bow tie
form Sean shares a touching sentiment
that highlights the importance each man
has in the other's life even calling
Glassman his father
I love you Dr Glassman although Sean
faces many challenges building
relationships at St Bonaventure he forms
a strong workplace friendship with
Audrey Lim however their relationship
sours after Sean's split-second surgical
decision leaves Lim partially paralyzed
the trouble arises when Dr Lim and
another doctor are attacked during
Sean's wedding at the end of season five
forcing Sean and Glassman to perform
emergency surgery with the hospital
still under lockdown in the season six
opener after party while operating on
limb Sean goes against glassman's order
performing a slightly riskier procedure
that saves her but causes her paralysis
as she struggles to accept her new
reality Lim targets her anger on Sean
believing his recklessness cost her the
ability to walk a position that's
unfortunately reinforced by glassman's
own feelings about Sean's decision when
Sean doesn't seem to understand how
resentful limb is she brutally spells it
out for him telling Dr Murphy that she
no longer wants to be friends in a big
sign
that's all
I don't want you to ask me about my
personal life
and I don't want to hear about yours
fortunately for all involved Sean is
nothing if not persistent and he
continues to work on ways to get her
Mobility back despite Lim's anger while
Lim continues to Harbor resentment
towards Sean she eventually begins to
embrace her new way of living with help
from Danny who underwent a lake
amputation years prior despite the
strain on their relationship Sean's
commitment to repairing Lim's nerve
damage pays off when he finds a way to
get her walking again however Sean has
to make things right with limb first in
the episode sorry not sorry he tells her
he does not owe her an apology as he did
save her life but admits he is sorry the
decision caused her harm he further
opens up telling limb he misses their
personal relationship I have missed your
friendship
[Music]
I have missed you Lim reveals she's
working through her anger but she's
finally in a good place and Mrs Sean's
friendship too it's good to see Lim and
Sean make up but more importantly the
moment shows Sean's growth as a surgeon
Sean's Revelation that he isn't
remorseful or guilty while still
expressing empathy for Lim shows his
Humanity without compromising his
confidence in his ability to make the
hard calls he'll need to keep making
going forward
Sean and his colleagues find themselves
in the tug of war between quality care
and financial constraints when the saint
Bonaventure is bought by the overbearing
Salen while she saves the hospital from
Financial ruins Salin shifts everything
to a heavily profit-driven system and
begins weighing money over human lives
at first Sean weathers the changes
surprisingly well while he tends to
resist change he can understand the
logic behind many of salin's decisions
however when salin's Corner cutting with
expired medications costs a baby her
life Sean's rage boils over in the
episode expired triggered by the recent
loss of his own infant he makes his way
to the hospital pharmacy where he
smashes bottles of expired medications
and lashes out at everyone around
feeling he can't trust anyone blaming
Glassman for the baby's death and
telling Leah that he can't marry her you
lied to me I can't trust you
and I can't marry you while it's a dark
moment that leaves a serious Rift in
Sean's relationship with Leah the
Meltdown marks a turning point that
leads to the staff's active Rebellion
against Salen
one of the more heartbreaking story
lines in the good doctor is Sean and
Leah's painful journey to Parenthood as
Leah's pregnancy progresses they learn
they're having a baby girl and get
excited about their new family member
however their happiness falls apart when
Leah experiences a brutal late pregnancy
loss in Dr Ted over time the couple
begins to move on past their grief
eventually getting married and looking
forward to starting a family once they
get the medical okay however Sean and
Leah are met with even more bad news
when they learn Leah has asherman's
syndrome a condition that will likely
affect Leah's fertility and ability to
carry the baby to term in Boys Don't Cry
although they want to be parents the
parent is understandably terrified when
Leah gets pregnant again in broken or
not and their fears are confirmed when
they learn her uterus is thinning and
has a high probability of rupturing Sean
devises a surgical plan to increase
their odds but while recovering in the
hospital Leah experiences a bleed from
her scar tissue in quiet and Loud
Glassman tells Sean that Leah and the
baby Will Survive only because they were
all already in the hospital for Sean's
procedure
among the many difficult figures Sean
encounters while working at St
Bonaventure few are more divisive than
Dr Jackson Han played by Daniel Day Kim
whose arrogance as a surgeon is
unrivaled among the staff after Marcus
Andrews ascends to hospital president
his position is filled by Dr Han who
finds Sean's interactions with other
staffers and patients inappropriate for
a position in surgery after Sean upsets
a mother With An Inconvenient Truth
About Her infant Han confronts him only
to be dumbfounded at Sean's lack of
social awareness about his own
interaction with the young resident in
risk and reward despite Sean's
colleagues insistence that he is working
on social cues hanfields Murphy isn't
fit for the role of surgeon after
telling Sean he is a remarkable
diagnostician Han moves him into the
Pathology Department believing it's a
better fit for Sean's social skills for
Sean who has dreamed of becoming a
surgeon since his youth the move is a
bitter pill to swallow in Breakdown Sean
is brought in to consult on a later
surgery at melendez's request he
confronts Han about getting his job back
but ends up having a meltdown and that
gets him fired
I am a surgeon
I am a surgeon Hans handling of the Sean
situation widens the rift between
himself and Andrews who ends up firing
Han and getting Sean his old job back in
trampoline
with all Sean and Leah go through
together it's nice to see them finally
get their happy ending however because
it's the good doctor even their wedding
turns out to be a tricky Affair after
struggling to heal from their tragic
pregnancy loss the episode vamos sees
Sean and Leah get engaged while on a
medical mission in Guatemala by the time
of their engagement party everyone is
looking forward to the upcoming nuptials
but the stress of wedding planning
already has Leah struggling in New
Beginnings if that wasn't enough
pressure they agreed to be part of a
streaming reality series culminating in
an on-screen wedding however when the
big day comes they hate everything about
it and decide to cancel their wedding
moments before show time just when it
starts to seem like they'll never tie
the knot Sean and Leah decide to get
hitched in a courthouse wedding before
they can Dr Glassman and Jordan throw
together a surprise rooftop wedding with
all of their friends present it's a
perfect moment for an unconventional
couple even if their fairy tale ending
is cut short when the hospital goes on
lockdown
[Music]